im oberfränkischen heiligenstadt gibt es
seit über 100 jahren das
lebensmittelgeschäft der familie sponsel
der traditionsbetrieb hat auf
energiesparen umgestellt mittlerweile
ist der laden komplett co2 neutral die
sponsel kaufen sich eine neue
energiespar tiefkühl anlage ersetzen die
neonröhren durch led-lampen und bauen
eine wärmerückgewinnungsanlage ein
90.000 euro haben sie aus eigener tasche
ausgegeben aber für sein vorbildliches
energiesparen wird karl hans sponsel
jetzt bestraft wie mir die erste arbeit
gekommen waren wir natürlich geblendet
und man kommt sich wege fast vor weil
diese ganz logisch investiert in neue
technik und spart strom und plötzlich
wird bestraft und zahl mehr kann ich
zeigen kann einfach nicht sein weil die
sponsel so sparsam sind hat sich ein
rechnungsposten von 105 euro auf sage
und schreibe 1375 euro erhöht es handelt
sich um die sogenannte konzessionsabgabe
die muss jeder verbraucher zahlen weil
die stromleitungen über öffentlichen
grund laufen grossverbraucher bekommen
einen rabatt auf diese abgabe dieses
privileg gilt aber für die sponsel es
nicht mehr weil sie so viel energie
sparen deshalb macht sich herr sponsel
mit einer irren aktion wieder künstlich
zum großabnehmer er schliesst zwei mal
im jahr sieben heizlüfter an und lässt
sie volle pulle laufen zusätzlich öffnet
er mitten im sommer die tiefkühltruhen
dadurch verbrauchte supermarkt eine
halbe stunde lang über 30
kilowattstunden wie vom gesetzgeber
gefordert entweder bezahlen wir müssen
mehr zahlen oder wir lassen uns was
kreatives einfallen wie die heizlüfter
es ist pure verschwendung aber nur so
wird der supermarkt pro forma wieder zum
großabnehmer die folge die sponsel
bekommen fürs vergeuden den satten
rabatt absurd finden dass auch die
kunden
wenn jemand für energie für umwelt was
tut und sport dann kann man nicht
bestraft werden das versteht man ist
dass es absolut unterirdisch das geht
überhaupt nicht geändert werden müsste
die verordnung über die
konzessionsabgaben durch das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium aber aus
berlin bekommen wir eine erstaunliche
antwort
uns liegen keine hinweise zu einer
problemstellung bezüglich der
konzessionsabgabe vor
sie ist ausgewogen ausgestaltet jedoch
könnte sie auch hier in einzelfällen zu
verhaltens anpassungen führen dass die
sponsel es zu einer bekloppten aktion
gezwungen werden ist für das ministerium
also nur eine anpassung des verhaltens
normale bürger halten es ganz einfach
für völlig verrückt ich finds
fürchterlich und eigentlich abschreckend
was sie denen den kleinen geschäfte
alles zumuten
das ist unverschämt es wirklich
unverschämt da der gesetzgeber nichts
ändern will müssten die sponsel es also
weiterhin gegen jede vernunft zweimal im
jahr energie verschwenden notwehr mit
heizlüftern sozusagen es geht halt nicht
anders